ask you a question let's go to Jonathan
there so Jonathan is a trump supporter
Jonathan feel free to ask the question
from Vivek ramaswani well I'm a Vivek
supporter and uh I believe you're the
best candidate for the nomination
although I think you have a huge uphill
battle against Trump's Die Hard Die Hard
supporters I also like Trump's policies
but I thought you would be a better
you'll be better at uniting the people
how do you plan to win over the Die Hard
Trump supporters
well it starts by being helpful that I
was one and and in many ways I stand by
it
but I'll tell you this the America First
agenda and I think most of the Die Hard
Trump supporters are really die hard
America supporters
America First does not belong to one man
it does not belong to trump it doesn't
belong to me it belongs to you
the people of this country so the
question you have to ask is this
movement belongs to We the People is
bigger than any of us
it's bigger than Trump it's bigger than
me it's bigger than any one of us I'm a
George Washington America First
conservative actually
and so here's the fact of the matter
that's why I'm in this race
I'm pursuing many of Trump's policies I
am you know there's some small things
here and there we'll do differently by
and large same policies in many cases
going further
use the military on the southern border
not just the wall shut down the
Department of Education not just Betsy
DeVos
but
but for whatever reason right Trump I
don't blame him for this it's just a
fact
about 30 percent of this country becomes
psychiatrically deranged when he's in
the white house and I I can't explain it
to you but it's just a fact it's like a
law of physics in American politics
and I'm not having that effect on people
maybe it's the fact that I'm a first
generation American skinny kid with a
funny last name and live the American
dream I'm grounded in principles not
Vengeance whatever it is
that will allow me at once to go further
with the same agenda than Trump did keep
in mind I pushed his people on why they
didn't eliminate affirmative action
which they could have done with the
stroke of a pen it was created by an
executive order they said it was a
political Hill they didn't want to die
on and I understand that but you have to
play the political Calculus if 30 of the
country is automatically against you but
if you're bringing the entire country
with you right
hey I went to the south side of Chicago
two months ago I went to Kensington in
the middle of Philadelphia last month
these are places Republican candidates
don't go and what are we finding
people agree with a lot of these
policies actually these aren't
Republican or Democrat bosses these are
pro-american policies
and so I think we have a chance and this
is why I think I'm going to do better
than anybody else in this race at this
to at once go further with the America
First agenda than Trump did but also
unite the country in the process
and I know Donald Trump I think he cares
about National Unity actually
he's misunderstood
but if he was capable of delivering it
we'd be there already
and we're not
and I have a vision of how we will get
there not by compromising on our
principles
but by being uncompromising
about the 1776 ideals that set this
nation into motion
and honest to God right now I couldn't
have told you this in March
I'm confident we're going to be
successful not only winning this primary
but winning this general election in a
landslide which could be the single most
unifying Catalyst for this country next
November thank you man thank you
[Applause]
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]